je suis sortie du collège j'ai débuté
avec un crp cuisine en deux ans je les
eu et j'ai suivi par un c ap pâtisserie
six mois on a neuf mois j'ai choisi ce
métier car ça me passionne depuis tout
petit et je voulais découvrir à fêter
quoi travail de la pâtisserie carton
nous dire et la pâtisserie sais pas
c'était facile mais c'est pas facile du
tout quand on arrivait qu'on découvre
c'est quoi ça enchaîne les chloride
avait satisfait ça vient beaucoup de
travail je suis deux semaines à l'école
de st mellons l'entreprise on n'apprend
plus son apprentissage que au lycée il
nous montre les bases comment ça
fonctionne comme on coud comment on fait
les glaçage s'appuie un autre prise il
ya plus de choses à faire
il ya plus de variété que à l'école ici
par exemple ils vont nous dire de faire
ou qui la brioche alors que là bas c'est
tout le temps des nouveautés ça
s'enchaîne sur c'est une étape sur dix
en fait ici c'est un sur cinq
là bas c'est un sur dix il ya plus de
choses je recommande donc plus on gagne
de l'argent en étant jeune
donc on may day l'étape suivante là je
fais finir mon année après j'ai
poursuivre avec un ace et un petit three
chocolaterie gars si mon objectif à me
wade vraiment ma propre boîte
le pâtissier pâtisseries traditionnelles
tous qui échoue avec la crème
puisqu'elle et patachou avec de la camsa
xd plus en ce moment
je voudrais reprendre tout ce qui était
de l'ancienneté remettre de nouveau
enfin nouveauté